[Musique]
des enfants bonsoir
quelle drôle d'odeur et de la fumée
patron mon casque de pompier aimons les
chaises de pompiers
[Musique]
popopopop au pot à son nounours athènes
un peu de fumée et le voilà qui
s'affolent
changea les marins changent la rade à
marange à
hop hop un pour les pompiers arrivent ou
elf ou
du tout sexy boy un moment il y avait
des flammes formidable oui comme dans la
forêt comme quand on fait un feu de camp
mais à présent il ya des marrons chauds
si pour l'anniversaire de ma peau puis
ma capuche et un bon jour
[Musique]
elle mademoiselle k prise venez vite
sens et voshix
et voile marjo
[Musique]
bonne anniversaire
ma poupée joli mais oui ma chère c'est à
fait aujourd'hui
d'arabe et nouvelle tout en organdi
qui est bien belle avec des brins
d'herbe
à poux pêcheurs eu ma poupée cheru c'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut chanter moi je
vais vous apprendre une belle chanson
écoutée troll halal là on nous la
liberté à nous la lui barre
ralala à la liberté
liberté
[Musique]
jobson salut je reviendrai jouer demain
voilà patron je m'amuse à vue
[Musique]
du calme les enfants il est l'heure de
dormir à présent alou malu malu malu la
lipr eu à nous la liberté
deviens bien turbulent ne nous faut pas
trop ce qu'on s'est amusé ce qu'on leur
hip hop au ce qu'on arrive pourtant
mieux mais il faut être raisonnable et
les enfants doivent dormir ces oeuvres
lui lance
eau en route
route bonne nuit faites de beaux rêves
faute de boer eux
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]